this week we've got stop snitching new
emojis and lost-and-found
do we care about emojis anymore oh
that's nice in the first one oh I love
the Lawson's on I used to love the waist
mouth no no not like old clothes but it
had this discomfort to it alright so the
first story I never had family so made
me feel warm inside to smell other
people's smells that was a wait for it
if I've ever heard
all right the New York Police Department
NYPD and they sent a cease-and-desist
letter two ways the google-owned
traffic oh no cuz a warning about work
outside yeah that's the only reason why
I use Waze yeah so they're saying that
that app is reporting where there's DWI
traffic points Oh checkpoint okay that
makes no what's wrong with that but
they're alerting people that are
intoxicated to avoid these checkpoints
and so their continued driving on the
road but those checkpoints don't work
anyways you're booking a drink anyways
I've seen people who we're definitely
you know sauced or something get through
those things really ya know I've seen
people get pulled over there in the car
with me I was right you know in high
school in high school what I'm like
drinking and I'm driving right and I see
the lane of cars I go oh [ __ ]
check stop and then just just take
another turn like those things all work
how do they not pull over every youtuber
I know right why are you doing YouTube
what are you doing to your tears if it's
left the lines long enough there's like
ten cars you could see it coming you
just go away sometimes they have bike
cops just ready to like get the people
that do oh you really yeah
I'd be like they're like hey sir why did
you perform u-turn I'm like cuz there's
a liquor store
right there but yes so they're saying
it's not safe for you know Public Safety
to be alerting all these people are
intoxicated but then they're also a lot
of people are like nothing's gonna
happen
like Waze is still gonna keep it because
a lot of the times the Department
themselves will announce where there's
checkpoints yeah why did they do it
because then there's a lot of apps to I
don't know just to avoid I guess for the
people that aren't drunk who would luck
but the drunk people who are like how do
I get to Taco Bell mm-hmm
okay go around that checkpoint people
who don't [ __ ] drink don't look at
that [ __ ] yeah they just don't do it I
don't even know where to get that
announcement like did they post fliers
or like they'll have that sign with like
you know those freeway signs like Oh
take the detour that's like all like
amber LED oh yeah sometimes they'll post
out like a week early there's gonna be a
checkpoint here what they should do is
be like Taco Bell is giving away burrito
Supremes here don't people net and you
[ __ ] pull it up and [ __ ] flop you
drunk people they gotta get a better way
to cut and catch these drunk we used to
do that when we went out and so
depending on who would go home first
they would always let us know where the
with a DUI checkpoints on the length
okay on my 15 and fourth whatever just
don't go there and then we would just do
that well it's just not I mean we live
in it in an era now where we don't have
to drive ourselves anymore I know
there's there's a [ __ ] app like let's
just stop doing every celebrity I see it
gets busted for drunk driving I'm like
what the [ __ ] Mel Gibson you are richer
than all yeah how do you not have a
butler driver person or Oberto Oberto
yeah do to get out of air tov not that
bad you could do afford it yeah cuz like
I'm wondering when you had that type of
money the whole world is your [ __ ]
oyster you could have whatever the [ __ ]
you but jail has a good point though
like everyone has that at our fingertips
now like maybe ten years ago yeah yeah
babe it's an even more I'm like Mel
Gibson have a hooker drive you home yeah
it doesn't matter yeah she wasn't
drinking but what if the over drivers
are drinking now
what if he got the uber drivers yeah
what if you're sober and you're in the
back but the uber drivers matricula Mel
Gibson can literally get four tiny
Indian men to grab a carpet lift them up
so he could be Aladdin and take them off
that's how rich he is yeah you know from
California in New York men like that
yeah so I don't understand and he's like
why I'm taking a flying carpet and then
the and then people were like that
carpet doesn't fly and then he's like
yeah I'm like that carpet flies Wow
flying carpet it's amazing whole [ __ ]
stadium of people and they're all like
wow - flying carpets are credible that's
how rich he is you know murderers they
can pretty much reject someone that's
super super intoxicated cause anyone
from throwing up in the car I wonder if
there's like a service out there where
it's like we want those mega [ __ ] up
people that uber drivers reject and Wool
like have this like again it's like
plastic proof yeah like the super placed
car
oh yeah police car you could throw up in
the back of that thing police are busy
and I like a whole nother term our
service service no he's saying just that
car use a crowd would call a patron they
stuff someone in the kennel Oh get a
u-haul have you ever been oh god they're
really gonna throw in the back of a
police car before yeah so you must have
liked living kadesha Scranton [ __ ] man
we are how come I mean it was it could
it's like it's like you have an [ __ ]
friend that chooses to put his seat as
far back as possible
I wasn't I didn't know it's just [ __ ]
crammed I think you were just fat then
yeah the back of it is just all plastic
- it's [ __ ] cramped yeah it's all
plastic it hurts I remember being like
[ __ ] light you're just fat bro
alright for our next story there are 230
new emojis coming out this year morning
miss you too many now that I don't even
use them I know only use like the like
five and I'm done there have to be
pretty universal I use like two which
one the Laughing I use this one and then
a thumbs up tip sends meowing - we do we
like this one well the reason why they
have so many emoji is because they have
to be inclusive
yeah yeah so these are the new that's
all bees every shade of color person
yeah I love it yeah you're not yeah
three someone's look at what is that
orgy one no so they're showing the
different skin tones free oh I thought
it was like a [ __ ] group of people no
it's like guys holding hands of every
color every combination pauses I think
guys holding hands with other guys of
every color covers yeah oh my god and so
they have all these combos available why
don't they have a pregnant lady holding
a guy's hand
exactly they have a pregnant lady
holding another woman's hands yeah and
why are they all the same height what of
them aren't amputated yeah well they do
have white what about tall really told
the arm and a leg
hmm what about really tall guys are
really short with more like a really
short guy with a really tall girl what
about - really yeah we really what about
two guys doggystyle on the floor why is
it shameful that they [ __ ] each other
how about the Mormons and all this like
they should be having one guy with ten
wives yeah what's up with that he loves
them all equally yeah and the Jehovah's
Witness with two guys on a tang of
basketball they should have just made
the person just a [ __ ] weird color
like blue that's why I love the old the
old emoji yellow was fun though it's
like nobody's yellow maybe two closes
skin tone oh no oh no like compared to
blue or green or purple egg yellows
closer I just love that they gotta be
blue now - not to offend anybody because
it makes me feel like it's a Sun just
know the happy faces yeah yeah happy
face happy face yellow they should have
just kept it that way
Forrest Gump invented that remember and
how often does anybody you really use
those [ __ ] things anyways the couple
of being holding hands should like what
the [ __ ] is that teenagers they have a
lot of time to look through all the
emojis okay what does it even mean it's
like a couple yeah wait there's we
trying to communicate there's four
variations of wheelchair yeah so there's
a
annual one an electric one wow they have
waffles without butter cuz I don't like
butter on my wall there's garlic there's
lemon there's a skunk
so they've announced all these right 230
new ones but the one emoji people are
focusing on is this one small dick small
big thing that's the small dick emoji
that's good it should be amazing my
patients are like a measurement well
it's like just a little pinching hand
yeah I thought that poquito it's like
the Condoleezza Rice meme where she it's
like she's saying that people have small
dicks I love that she's dead yeah well
cuz she's of the UN's to give a speech
about something and then everyone's like
yeah she say anything goes is the last
time oh just a black glove David it's a
magician's hand David from this angle it
just looks straight a black eye things
are wrong it's a robbers good glove okay
see that now looks brown because if you
look from my angle it's just all black
yeah everyone's like finally a small
dick emoji and another one damaging a
damaging blow to the dick pic economy
and then a number of dick pics cent
plummets tinder team's about to get
amazing yeah well they need they need
one of these two to go oh yeah you feel
excluded Wow not me not me
like don't like this stuff I know should
we just ashamed small day people it's
like you should also reward people with
bigger dicks yeah because if they send
it if I send dick dick and it's like and
you get you you only get that you should
have the option for the other yeah you
should also have in other words just
like this we're just like it's okay it
just moves a little bit like this I
really good Jeff emoji yeah just like
baby next level like how was that
[ __ ] dick last night it's just what
they should have is an app that cuz
girls don't like getting dick pics right
unless it's from the person that they
love I pull people all the time on this
so far I've gotten knows but they should
do a thing where the phone can recognize
him the guys sending a dick pic and it
doesn't send it but it's it looks like
it was sent and on the other end a girl
gets a [ __ ] batch of flour
Casey sends you a dick pic right it gets
it looks like it was sent from his phone
but you never get the dick pic because
the phone recognizes that he saw you're
saying that this should be a feature can
ask yeah because what you actually get
is five dollars
his account oh that's easy that's it I
want that damn you never send dick pics
do you want more no I want one do you
actually want to duplicate your husband
yeah I'll send right now no you should
make it your bed you go to the bathroom
I know bro right now I keep better now
you want a hard one to give a mid mid
fluff one bro no I want Martin I want
the veins and everything oh holy mother
[ __ ] for Valentine's Day you should
send her like really nice dick pics with
like like nice lighting and they have
like a cool background yeah yeah like
take off all the flowers I don't want
like it's a bouquet of flowers I want to
be camp Dix oh that's really but your
did not the Photoshop all that all your
dick yeah I'm not worried oh you know
what would be great dude and I'm just
clarifying just put a bed of McDonald's
fries and then just a few chicken
nuggets around and a double cheeseburger
and just lay your dick right next to it
oh that's really nice and in right now
loving it
okay this is what you're gonna see at
the front I'm gonna get a bunch of gummy
worms lay it down oh yeah yeah no you
don't want anything for size comparison
that we bear it no dude I'm thinking
just a bunch of maybe gummy bear
flower-petal yeah that was a really fast
really stop fighting there is gummy
roses you could wrap that around like a
bouquet but why the dicks in this whole
thing just get your dick that'll be the
spin get a [ __ ] fruit roll-up and just
keep wrapping it around your dick oh my
god to make a rose yeah oh that's pretty
good fruit by the fuzzy stuff for your
Mexico trip she has to unwind the whole
thing before you have sex and then she's
like when did you put this on you like
before I got on the plane and she's like
yeah why this for roll-ups aller
Yeah right yeah good gifts go bad anyway
moving on to our last story so in New
Zealand New Zealand's National Institute
of water and Atmospheric Research that's
not like a fun job yeah so this they
study water and atmospheres so they
tweeted out that they're searching for
the owner of a USB stick that was found
in
frozen poop of a leopard seal so a
leopard seal ate their [ __ ] they dropped
it in the water and then the seal made
it they pooped it out but then the poop
would solve it they could still use it
they found it because they have
volunteers that scooped up seal poop so
they can does that look like looking
when I see what have you guys seen a
peacock [ __ ] no oh my god multicolored
so we sh so we've been how something as
you guys know and in one of these
neighborhoods they're known for having a
[ __ ] - the peacocks talking [ __ ] ton I'm
talking orgies every corner yeah I know
what never go down this this street we
see a house we like and there's like
eight peacocks in front of it so we're
like oh my god that's so cool cause like
walk on a driveway the guys trying to
court the chick so he's like feathers
all spread on all beautiful and [ __ ] so
I like walking up to it and then we see
like these chihuahuas sighs [ __ ] we're
like what the [ __ ] where are they shit's
everywhere and there were all peacock
shits cuz I was like I was like oh sure
there's peacocks you know it's a bird
and then I'm like dog [ __ ] I said it was
a talking right now I do and you're
saying that uh you don't think so
because birds don't [ __ ] like that and
then we didn't find out until her age I
think that's what she said but a hot dog
[ __ ] it's like it's like a pile of
bananas like this big no no but it looks
like it's about yes Oh like a little
permanent yeah and then my birds are
supposed to [ __ ] like [ __ ] mammals
and [ __ ] yeah cuz imagine you get one of
those on your car like for them all over
your car like it [ __ ] bird [ __ ] looks
like like egg but instead of yellow it's
black in the middle yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude I remember the first day I high
school this chick before first period
started we're all getting our schedules
and this chick got [ __ ] bird [ __ ] on
by a eagle or something it was like
splat [ __ ] first [ __ ] class of
high school freshman year they sit like
oh we call a bird [ __ ] girl after that
every [ __ ] day
now there's like a statistic of like 90
some odd percent the world will get shat
on by a bird at least once or something
like I've never got I got [ __ ] on twice
I never I never I got [ __ ] on when I was
sitting on the stairs of my grandma's
apartment and my brother had got into a
fight so I had like ran out of steam so
I was like sitting on this [ __ ]
stairs like this and I felt something go
plot I thought he'd threw something at
me I'm like what oh [ __ ] at you with
Casey and then I I felt someone throw
some [ __ ] at my hair and I was like what
the [ __ ] and I go like this yeah it
looks like somebody [ __ ] albatross
[ __ ] wide out the people behind us I
could hear them being like hands - case
that's awesome damn [ __ ] bird pissed
what the [ __ ] that's great and then they
had this weird thing where they're like
should we still ask for a picture
did they see what should happen to you I
think music oh [ __ ] he's like he's like
is it Zach green or is it Bob green and
I was like it's neither green bro I'm
just like the Larian people are green I
just love the immediate enthusiasm
there's no idea what my name is like
Tim's wife is is pretty [ __ ] funny is
like we were we're at the airport and
then this guy comes up Tim of course not
me but comes at him he goes hey it'll
Tim he's a man the ice watched him all
the time I don't watch it anymore what's
with that she goes okay what the [ __ ]
was the point of you saying that dude
[ __ ] say hi and go on I used to not
anymore yeah they gotta be cool like
what what the [ __ ] is the whole point
come here for a second are you still
doing videos I get that sometimes
are you video still say no why don't you
[ __ ] look it up dude yeah I'll just
be like this actually we're getting our
pork now so yeah I'm working
yeah he's like anyway so I did footage
from the USB Drive because they posted a
because they're trying to find the
owners it's a weird [ __ ] well I'm
curious no so I tried googling leopard
seal poop - I couldn't find it nudes
I don't have somebody's [ __ ] on a
paddleboard that's dumb I think it's a
good tire that's the one that ate it
haha they didn't want this work though
I'm a convert how cute is this a disc
seals remind me adult yeah they will
return the USB Drive to the owner but in
exchange they want the footage no they
want the owner to give them more seal
food like the owner of the USB Drive in
order to read also you have to go
volunteer and help pick up poop in the
Gotcha what a [ __ ] extortion yeah
what's the fines just a USB that shit's
like five bucks well that's probably a
joke just because that's rightfully his
you're stealing from if you don't give
it back Yeah right
yeah it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
that's unfun David going to pick up his
USB technically you're stealing from me
I'm not gonna it's like well this is
what you have to do and then make it a
joke I'm like no that's illegal we're
making a joke sorry no oh but sir it's
kind of we're around the office we're
having fun I don't think you [ __ ]
understand
[Music]